compara los dos valores usando la recta
numérica debajo supón que la recta
numérica está dibujada a escala tenemos
entonces la opción de que 0 es mayor que
menor que o igual a x menos x que
significa x vamos a investigar dónde
está x x está a la izquierda del 0 lo
que implica que es un número negativo de
hecho está a la izquierda de menos 1 tal
vez entre -1 y -2 si hacemos un cálculo
más o menos así como rápido podemos
pensar que está en menos 1.6 lo ven aquí
está el menos 1 tenemos que éste es
menos 1.5 menos 1.6 es un número
estimado vamos entonces con nuestra
operación tenemos x que será menos 1.6
y a menos 1.6 le restamos menos 1.6 que
de hecho si estamos restando un valor
negativo lo que haremos es recorrer nos
hacia en la derecha en este caso
tendremos entonces menos 1.6 más 1.6 eso
nos implicará pues 0 así es que el 0
sería igual
a x - x
recuerda que si estamos restando un
número negativo lo que realmente haremos
es sumar el valor absoluto de este mismo
número
así es que haremos esto menos 1.6 menos
menos 1.6 será menos 1.6 más 1.6 eso nos
dará 0 vamos a comprobar la respuesta
y es correcta